[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
for me at Winston Marshall at The
Spectator the Online safety bill is
about to pass its third reading at the
House of Lords and at the 11th Hour Lord
Piers have tried to put in measures that
will mean tech companies like WhatsApp
will have to give over
encrypted messaging and at the same time
the Digital Services Act is passing
through in the EU and all the while
facial recognition is coming
up and we've just seen that the home
office are being lobbying for facial
recognition spy companies in the UK
um and here to discuss all that and a
lot more is the director of Big Brother
watch silky Carlos silky thank you so
much for coming to speak with me thanks
for having me
um so I am hoping to get an education in
some of these uh those things
aforementioned but I I wondered if we
could uh start if you if you don't mind
telling me and and listeners and viewers
a little bit about your work at Big
Brother watch and and how you came to be
interested in in this world of
surveillance and Free Speech issues
well um Big Brother watch is a UK
privacy in civil liberties or campaign
organization where non-profit
non-partisan and we work particularly at
the intersection of technology and human
rights which is where we see an enormous
increase in surveillance and now
increasingly censorship
um so we are tasked with trying to be
part of the a part of civil society that
helps to defend our liberal traditions
and that advances civil liberties in a
time where technology makes suppressing
them very much easier and I came into
this work
um I think because you know I grew up
with a very keen sense of civil
liberties because I grew up
um I think as did you in the
um counterterror years you know Post 9
when our civil liberties were being
eradicated like never before
um and then add to that the growth of
the internet and
um
Technologies to intercept Communications
monitor the internet so much has changed
um of course then we had a string of
very high profile whistleblowers
um kind of lift the lid on what the
intelligence agencies were doing and how
unchecked the powers were
um
exactly and that's where my career
um in this world really started was
um advocating around those disclosures
and and for those individuals so back
then it was we were told we need to give
up our liberties so that they can
monitor terrorists wherever they may be
and it now the conversation is about
protecting children and it's an
important conversation to have so I hope
we can get into into that but um before
doing that firstly I'd like I owe you an
apology because I've done a couple of
episodes and which have basically been
based on your minister Ministry of Truth
report from the beginning of this year
where you uh uncovered the the rapid
response unit the counter disinformation
unit the government information cell
intelligence community and
Communications unit and the 77th Brigade
IOU credit for that which I don't think
I properly gave you in previous episodes
and I and I encourage listeners and
viewers to find that report on the Big
Brother watch website but you've also
spoken it at length and on I've heard
some great interviews with trigonometry
and Russell Brand so that I really
encourage people to listen to I think
it's it's the kind of British arm of the
censorship industrial complex and I've
talked a lot about that staff with
people like a mutual friend with Michael
schellenberger and
um it's it's a big piece and even not
just the British but for the whole world
it's an important piece of that um so
but seeing as you've already spoken
about that maybe we won't go go into
that and I apologize for not crediting
not at all no it's great to have it
reference and it's great that it is
being discussed I think that it is
filtering through into the political
discussion I mean it's exactly what we
want to say that's great wonderful well
can we start please with the Online
safety bill
it's gone through many iterations it's
about to pass
but what are the basics what what is it
that is about to pass and how does that
affect me and you the Online safety bill
was the first comprehensive piece of
legislation that aims to kind of
formalize the relationship between the
state and social media companies
um and I think the
in essence what it does is creates some
legal duties on large social media
companies
um particularly around this notion of a
duty of care
um and so social media companies in the
UK now have a series of legal
obligations as to what they must and
must not do
um and on the surface of it some of this
sounds very sensible so
um things like they must take down
illegal content and their rules about
they have to make policies for how they
take down illegal content how quickly
they do it can they prevent it going
online in the first place things like
that
um
um which which sounds sensible and to
some degree it is I mean certainly you
need to have them involved
um with law enforcement to some degree
but what the bill does is effectively
makes these private companies
private police so they're adjudicating
what's unlawful and actually there is no
law enforcement process so it's not like
they see something that's concerning
that looks like it's very much unlawful
and there's plenty of it online we all
know about child sexual exploitation and
really serious issues
um
it's not like what the bill does is
create a process whereby that's
forwarded to the police and the police
work the platforms and no it's it's kind
of like a shove it under the carpet
approach so the companies have to deal
with it themselves they have to please
it themselves they have to monitor these
networks that have billions of
communications find this stuff get rid
of it or even prevent people from seeing
it so I think the intentions were in
places good the upshot is that we kind
of have privatized
are they being obligated to take down
what the British government or British
law considers illegal so
this sounds similar to what the CD you
were doing the counter disinformation
unit where they were flagging they were
favored flaggers I think is the term
trusted yeah and they were they with our
tax money
they were telling big Tech what content
could be misinformation disinformation
and should be taken down within the
rules of what big Tech those tech
companies are that within their rules so
how is this is this different is this
obligating those tech companies to take
that the content down as per the wishes
or is it telling the tech companies what
is already within their rules not
acceptable and to take it down well they
are obliged to do that I mean
from
Public Authority
um you you have to comply with it this
goes some step further it it effectively
deputizes foreign private media
companies to police domestic speech and
content I think on the most extreme end
of things of where you think about the
most manifestly obviously illegal
content
um that might not be too controversial a
task although I would have liked to see
something more about the police
involvement and how this becomes a
proper judicial process rather than just
a completely privatized one
um but actually it's a bit more
expansive than that and you know I'm
thinking for example
about how
um now we have so many anti-protest laws
um what will this mean in relation to
what kind of content can stay online
about certain types of protests and
protest organizing I mean there are some
really blurry nothing's more precious
than speech and the right to free speech
and the right to share information and
and receive information freely I'm very
uncomfortable with the idea of um kind
of corporatizing
um what is fundamentally a human right
by by exporting that responsibility to
foreign companies where it gets really
controversial of course is where the
government was seeking to
um go even further and create this whole
um notion of legal but harmful speech
that was also deserving of censorship
and um to some degree that still exists
for children but we did actually win the
campaign against that
um against restrictions around this
extraordinary category made of category
of speech in relation to adults
um so yeah the idea was that the
companies would have to make up rules
around harmful speech that's completely
lawful and then
enforce those basically to censor lawful
speech so we saw the non-crime hate
incidences this this kind of thing but
it wouldn't even need to be hate I mean
Define harm and then that's been
obviously a controversial Point as well
in the bill
um how have they landed on the bill with
that definition is it is it now just
illegal have they got rid of the idea of
harmful so the most of the powers that
will have will have impact are around
crime but where they've landed on this
legal but harmful thing is okay so we we
won in terms of for adults we we don't
have the legal but harmful
creation of a speech category but the
new rules are
um that the tech companies must
consistently enforce their terms and
conditions and then there is a string of
expectations around what those terms and
conditions are
um which is so they could include things
which aren't illegal and they do country
and they do include and they do so so
well Forex I mean they've been very
controversial things in the past haven't
they I mean of course you've had for a
long time all of the companies said
anything that doesn't Accord with World
Health Organization policies and views
on covid for example is not permitted on
the platform
um different platforms have had
different approaches to uh words like
CIS and turf or misgendering and all
these kinds of things
um some really controversial areas that
have created huge conversations around
speech which is
um one of the reasons that I find this
approach I think I think it would end in
in disaster because whereas before we
could say you know this is it's the it's
the domain of private companies they can
make whatever rules that they like
people can choose whether to be there or
not now actually the British government
has said to those companies you need to
have terms and conditions on various
different areas of speech and you must
enforce them and if you don't enforce
them you could be you could face serious
repercussions from ofcom
um so for example when Elon Musk not
that long ago decided that it would be
banned on the on Twitter or now X from
posting the whereabouts of his private
plane
you you have a state obligation now to
make sure that no one is posting about
Elon musk's plane on Twitter do you see
what I mean it's it's an uncomfortable
merging of
private terms and conditions with States
obligations which aggrandizes these
terms and conditions and I do think that
because of the declining Free Speech
culture that we've had in this country
um we have somehow come to a position
where we're we're accepting this very
corporatized privatized approach to free
speech from our perspective the main
thing that the government needs to be
saying to the platforms is
is is and the extent of the government's
responsibility is to protect its
citizens right to free speech and and
that means you actually have to
proactively do things to protect our
right to free speech what's actually
happened is we've gone in the opposite
direction where
um the government is encouraging
restrictions on perfectly lawful speech
do you think
um you mentioned there that the you you
had made a progress with the adults side
of things and so is is am I right and
understanding than this the the Online
safety bill has a different rule for
adults as it does for children yeah
what's the difference then so I mean
this is going to basically result in the
age gating of the internet and no one
really knows yet how that's going to
work out and are we going to need IDs to
go online
um and that we're seeing that as a
growing Trend as well that platforms are
saying you know they want to see
evidence of age whether that's giving
credit card or it could go towards
passports driving license is facial
recognition and I think these things are
likely that we'll see in in future years
because there's been such an emphasis on
young people's experience online and
shielding them from harm which is what
the bill aims to do now I think you
everyone is surely in agreement that the
internet can be an unpleasant place for
young people there are lots of risks you
can find some really horrible stuff kids
can be mean to each other
um you know it there are serious risks
with young people being online but I
think the idea
that you can you can
um
kind of export the responsibility for
protecting children away from parents
and towards tech companies
um is problematic and if you go down
that road you're going to end end up
collecting giving them license to
collect huge amounts of data and I
thought that was something that we all
agreed was controversial and bad it's
that you know we've got Facebook as more
information about the global population
than probably any intelligence agency in
the world
um and yet we're going to end up giving
them more and more data probably then
identity data and the right to control
what people can and can't see I think
that that responsibility needs to be
kind of on devices with parents in the
home
um yeah so I'm quite interested in that
in that how we actually help parents so
just for context the Online safety bill
came after the tragic suicide of Molly
Russell a 14 year old girl who'd uh I
think she was depressed and then
um because of negative stuff that she
discovered on on social media and it is
popular in Britain as and I'm sure you
you would agree if that we we want to
protect children not only with examples
like Molly Russell but let's say child
uh pornography or child sex trafficking
that there is a problem there and like
with islamist terrorists uh it's that's
most of us will be prepared to sacrifice
for those things we'll be prepared to
sacrifice some amount of our privacy
because we would see that as a a greater
evil but there are there are obviously
other consequences once you open that
door but given that assuming Maybe I'm
Wrong to assume that you you do think we
need to protect children in that sense
what is the correct policy that would
help
parents uh protecting their children and
protecting children I think I mean first
of all I think
um there has been a Temptation by
politicians and others to blame
everything on the internet any kind of
social problem and I think particularly
where mental health is concerned I think
it absolutely plays a role but I think
we have to be careful about particularly
where suicidality is involved about
attributing any one cause because
um from all the expertise in this area
it's never really that simple
um and there's there's often a
constellation of factors that are
involved in ill mental health
um and the internet is is in some cases
a factor may be a significant factor but
it's a factor
um and I think that has to be taken into
account I do think there's more that
um the platforms
can do and for example being open about
how the algorithms work I think is
really important because if you are
designing a product in a way where you
are
um feeding someone deliberately certain
types of of content of any type to be
honest with you and that raises some
some serious questions and people ought
to be able to often it's it's based on
your personal data you have rights over
your personal data for precisely this
reason so you should be able to know and
why am I seeing the world through this
lens it's a very powerful thing so I
think laws about transparency and
algorithms are really important so that
we know what the deal is when we're
having this online experience
um but to start you know to to some
degree as well I do think that nowadays
you know it's a
putting kids online in front of screens
is a is something that do
um
I'm I'm not going to be too I'm popular
for saying this but it's something that
a lot of parents are doing
um and then not always wanting to take
responsibility for what happens and you
know the the truth is that when you're
doing that you're just unlocking the
door to to the whole Global World and
putting it your child's fingertips so
you you have to take responsibility for
that and there's no amount of
um tech company control censorship data
collection ID collection that that is
going to fully mitigate that that
reality and I think we need to make
young people
um educated and literate about the
internet and how to use it and parents
likewise rather than just kind of
exporting that you know fundamentally
parental responsibility to uh you know
profit making companies so with let's
say pornography or child pornography and
this is what's come up this week at the
House of Lords is that with as I
mentioned earlier the uh they they want
act they want to give access to the
government for in encrypted messaging to
prevent sharp pornography which is
spread on telegram signal Etc
or do you
do you think that that's a bad thing
I disagree disagree with the premise
that that's why they want that power
and I'll explain why
um we so already
um encrypted services like WhatsApp for
instance send hundreds of thousands of
tips to
um a child exploitation helpline do they
yes
um and uh you know we we all know it's a
bit like when we have panics around
um
other types of of sexual violence
um which are merited but when you
actually look at how well reports are
investigated and policed it's often very
very poorly
so we have more data than ever on child
abusers because of the internet because
it's so visible because it's out there
and there's simply too much for them to
please so I disagree that there's a
problem with being able to find where
this stuff is going on there's
absolutely masses of it out there
um and it's under policed and I would
have taken all of that uh
premise that was used in the bill so
much more seriously if there were
anything in there about increasing
police capacity to investigate and
prosecute these crimes about how they
work with tech companies that there
isn't all there is is we we basically
need a key to see everyone's
Communications
um well I worked as in lobbied on a few
years ago a bill called the
investigatory Powers Act which was kind
of overhaul of our surveillance laws in
the UK
um if that's for a long long time for
decades we've had the the state
authorities have the ability to on a
targeted basis
get into encrypted Communications
so if you are a suspected child abuser
or terrorist
um you're don't think that your phone is
you know everything on there is going to
be private it's going to be accessed and
you know
um and so it should be
um on a targeted basis and in the
investigatory Powers Act
um a really really strong new powers on
that were were introduced as well
hacking Powers explicitly for the first
time on the
um statute book that you can not only
compel someone to hand over encrypted
Communications but you can actually hack
phones or with a lawful basis
um but what the did you support that I
think it was done it was done way too
broadly in the in the bill and actually
the the investigative Powers Act allows
the state to hack entire countries if it
wants to it's an absolutely massive
massive power but yes I do think that
that in a targeted manner hacking Powers
have a place absolutely I do think that
um what the Online safety Bill does is
um quite different it's not Spooks it's
not something that has judicial
authorization it's ofcom
um having the ability to require that
companies like WhatsApp meta signal
maybe
um encrypted Communications channels
redesign their software to put spyware
on your phone to look on your phone at
what images
and content you're sending
um it's called client-side scanning
um and that's really quite extreme it's
way more invasive it's it's
it it's as invasive I mean you've
basically got you've either the first
Power I reference is having your phone
hacked the second one is having spyware
on it I mean it's both you you don't
have control over your device in the way
that you that you should
um but the critically with this ofcom
power
it would mean that people have spyware
on their phones in a way that is not
targeted
you're talking about the whole
population everyone who uses WhatsApp
um it's kind of extraordinary when you
say the words out loud and realize how
bad things are
um how bad the state of privacy is in
this country that we so have devalued
the right to have a private conversation
that that it's it's a non-ridiculous
suggestion and actually survived in the
legislation to this day it's going to
pass that we can have the equivalent of
State microphones and cameras in our
pockets if I can quote the mighty Davos
man himself Klaus Schwab if you have
nothing to hide you have nothing to be
afraid of hmm to people who don't
have who are not worried about that who
feel like it's not going to come for
them it's not they're not going to you
know they're a normal person it's not
gonna it's not gonna come for them why
should they worry about this bill
well
um
I mean first of all if since most people
have nothing to hide the state should
have no interest in looking at your
Communications so I think already you
know it it creates uh you know that
there is we should all be aware there's
a problem there that they want to see
um what people are sending to each other
and I actually don't doubt that it would
start with looking for extreme uh
imagery for example but
people who have photos of their family
including young family children
um on the beach maybe you can see how
easily this can go wrong
um how people could be wrongly and
falsely accused which is something that
that happens but also that that most of
us want to protect those photos I
actually don't trust other people you
know probably men that I don't know
um you know who who you've never met
having a a lens into your into your
phone into your Communications
um that creates really significant risks
as well so I think there are kind of
obvious things to be worried about but
the bigger thing that we all ought to be
worried about is that we are losing the
right to have a private conversation and
we're losing the right to speak freely
um and they're under this very kind of
casual attack where people seem not not
quite aware about how how serious that
situation is and how much we are losing
those fundamental rights we've seen
Mission we don't need to really hammer
on about Mission creep at this stage
because we've seen it happen before how
maybe we started off with anpr cameras
as a counter-terror measure look what
road cameras are being used for now
um you know started with surveillance
and you know interception
um as a counter-terror terror measure
it's now being used uh for any any
number of things it's being used to kind
of monitor you know
the the population at large not just bad
people not just terrorist surprise
surprise what about undercover spies
people thought that they were targeting
serious organized crime gangs and again
terrorists we find out that they're
infiltrating environmental protest
groups
the way I see it and and or the way that
I'm concerned by it is if if this these
laws come in we are also seeing
simultaneously for example our great
mayor Sadiq Khan talking about the C40
cities and his uh where he's speaking of
Mayors from other cities across the
world and they they're discussing ways
to tackle the quote unquote climate
crisis with policy including that we'll
only be allowed to buy three pieces of
clothing a year fly once every three
years and we're seeing this already in
London with with Euless so they can use
this they could use this technology by
imagining to where as these new small
regulations come in to monitor us to see
and uh see whether we're breaking them
and this is also already happening in
China and we can talk about face
recognition because you've done a great
report on this because I think this
crosses over very neatly in there in
China they use face recognition to stop
you using public transport you need it
to you to get toilet paper public
restrooms you um and there's a whole
social credit system that's all used
like well it seems to me that the what's
frightening to me is is the creep there
if it's cheesy to say the word Mission
Creek but I think there is a mission
creep into that sort of these slow these
laws slowly coming through that we we
don't vote on that we don't necessarily
agree on which will which could have
serious impact on our uh our civil
liberties I think absolutely I think we
we are seeing and we'll see more of
surveillance used for policy enforcement
I mean wasn't that really the case
during covid to some degree that
surveillance was used as a as a as a
policy enforcer not just to catch
terrorists
um and particularly with
um one area that that's beginning and I
think we're going to see a bill on this
depending on elections
um and when that comes but um is
certainly around DWP and and benefits
using
um surveillance to to decide whether
somebody it could be involved in in
making welfare decisions certainly
in that in that area and I I've I'm
hearing on the Grapevine there's there's
more on that to come and the way that AI
might be used is with data collection
um in the welfare system which is very
concerning to us it's about casting this
huge net of Suspicion over the whole
population and people sit there at first
and say I'm not a terrorist so it's not
me I'm not this it's not me and then
yeah eventually it's the kind of thing
that that affects people
um and I I think actually as well
quite aside from facial recognition
we're seeing that Trend with the
disinformation in forces as well because
the kind of the
the the act of monitoring the internet
and speech at large is is certainly not
a it's not a counter-terror measure
um and it's about narrative and it's
about
um promoting Authority or you know
Authority is the is the quote that's
often used
um and to some degree narrative control
and that's a lot what what I think we've
uncovered in the ministry of Truth
investigation that we did
can I ask you a side question just on
the on the issue of uh these tech
companies do you consider them the
Public Square
so for free speech to be protected
we have to accept that that is the
Public Square
large social media companies form part
of the Public Square yeah because
legally I don't think that's the case in
America legally the pr the precedent is
and this goes back to 1970 uh it was
Lloyd Corp versus Tana where some
Vietnam anti-vietnam War protesters were
putting leaflets out in a shopping mall
and it went ended up going all the way
to Supreme Court and uh the protesters
lost because the Supreme Court decided
that the shopping malls were private
property and so in if that is a
continuation of of that precedent
then these big tech companies Twitter
Etc they are uh private companies and
they have no responsibility to protect
our speech now it's slightly different
when as we're seeing in Missouri versus
Biden that the government is
encouraging or even uh scaring them into
silencing people that is explicitly
breaking the First Amendment as we're
seeing but with the companies themselves
if they are private do they is it really
the Public Square I mean of course
there's a this is a huge debate there
there are differences between the US and
the European UK model on this as well
because we have the European convention
on human rights of course and that means
that the British government has a duty
to protect our freedom of speech
um
in this country and and certainly in
terms of discrimination I mean you can't
you can't censor people in a
discriminatory way whether you are a
Public Authority or um
a private company unless it's really
really Justified
um we also have the expectation that
companies because of
um
businesses have signed up to protect
human rights effectively at the
international level we have the
expectation that they protect
um the right to free speech and all of
them say that they do
I think part of the problem that we have
is that our
the the kind of shared understanding of
what freedom of speech means and what
privacy means has shifted so much like
our understanding of what these civil
liberties are the the right to free
speech
um it sounds cliche to say because it's
such a basic standard but it does seem
to be missed particularly between people
you know even a bit younger than us the
the right to free speech is not it is
for people that you disagree with and
speech that you don't like and that is
offensive as much as it is for anything
else and unless you're defending that
type of speech you're not defending the
right to free speech and I think
particularly on the left unfortunately
that's something that's just been lost
because you don't really see people on
the left so much defending
um speech rights for people that that
you know offend maybe their principles
and and points of view
um there has been a whole realignment on
on this and I think particularly where
disinformation is concerned in
particular
um
this whole it that that's the litmus
test for how much we've we've lost track
of what freedom of speech really means
of course in a world where you have free
speech you you have the right and
ability
um and in fact it's a necessity to be
wrong about things that's how you
discover what's right that's like a
Enlightenment rationality principle
isn't it that is through the Journey of
Discovery and testing ideas and making
mistakes that you that you arrive at
truth you don't arrive at Truth by
listening to a centralized Global
Authority and then saying yes I will
repeat that you know which was like the
World Health Organization kind of model
during covid where you know top down uh
was was the model of like truth
Discovery and it's that's quite
disturbing and and
um indeed when did uh you know bad ideas
unless there is the free speech for the
truth to knock them off their their
perch they run right so it's an absolute
necessity you mentioned uh Europe and
disinformation so the the digital
service
act which I don't think is yet so
Digital Services act which is not yet
um in action uh but it is seems to me to
be the the EU equivalent of the Online
safety bill yeah although they
explicitly
say that they will protect freedom of
expression as under article 10 of the
um you're being called for human rights
but they also say they're going to
tackle disinformation as part of their
remit
what what do I need to know about the
Digital Services Act is it the same
thing as the Online safety bill it's
very similar
a force for the big
I think further obligations come into
Force for smaller companies down the
line
um and it obliges companies to develop
um methods and rules on a series of of
online harms essentially
um
some of which are sensible some of which
are around misinformation and
disinformation if they're not deemed to
be doing enough on those issues
um then they can be fined significant
amounts as under the Online safety bill
so so yeah there's internationally there
have been lots of pieces of legislation
that are very similar in this respect
that it's like um
a mixture of hard and soft power because
yes it's it's legislative
um they're legal obligations but they're
quite Willy they're saying that you know
the states are basically saying to these
companies you have to take Serious
action on uh misinformation
disinformation
or else and you decide what you want to
do about that now of course with the
threat of fines hanging over them
um they're going to take quite Extreme
Action and you know in terms of then
deciding what's misinformation What's
disinformation
um you know effectively often where that
ends up with the threat of State uh
issued fines over your head is that you
allow what states like and you know and
get rid of what they don't like and
what we found in the ministry of Truth
investigation obviously it happens in
the it has happened in the US and it's
happened in the EU is that there's this
hotline between government departments
and
um content moderation teams
at social media companies where they can
relay the things that they think
exactly and we saw that in the ministry
of Truth investigation that we did in
the UK so for example
we know that the requests or they don't
call them requests
um it's a bit more like you should take
a look at this that comes from the these
flags that come from the UK government
and we found that of all the flags that
went from the UK government to Twitter
during the pandemic
sixty percent of them
um didn't violate Twitter rules which is
extraordinary that that tells us you
know for all the limited information we
have about what was going on that's a
really worrying indication of how far
they were going because we're certainly
talking about lawful speech okay this is
not unlawful speed anything on North
would have to come down straight away
bearing in mind at the time the rules
were unless
um a point of view accorded with with
the World Health Organization then it
could be deemed misinformation it wasn't
breaching that rule then
um presumably so you know the the rules
on on Twitter
despite musk I'm not having any you know
of this but you know now it's a free
speech Zone I don't that just factually
doesn't check out at all
um but you know the rules are expansive
now they were very expansive then
60 of these flags not even breaching
Twitter rules I mean what the hell is
going on we've got censorship a
censorship Drive coming from the heart
of government
going to to private companies to try and
suppress the voices of British people
saying lawful things I really think this
is something that deserves
um a full investigation so this is
something I don't and get and I wonder
whether he had insight into it which is
that it seems to be part of the
motivation that Elon Musk bought Twitter
was that he was seeing these sort of
things and he being a free speech
absolutist I guess or at least at the
time was as concerned as you clearly are
and wanted to do something about it and
yet with the digital Services act it
seems the little research I've done to
it is that he supports that that seems
to be very confusing to me particularly
with this disinformation tackling
disinformation given that that's such a
loose term it could mean anything do you
think why would he support this bill
I think well first of all I think that
he's
very confused about his Free Speech
principles
um
and and he's kind of
or clearly he's gone head first into a
kind of culture War
um approach to it in my view
um if he is serious about Free Speech
I'd ask that he publishes all of the
requests that have come from the UK
government about censorship which we've
asked in writing we've got good contacts
at Twitter we've we've made this request
at high levels if he is watching then I
would ask that he publishes and
discloses that in full I think that
would show a serious commitment to free
speech
um that hasn't happened
there are the continuation of rules that
go far beyond the rule of law in terms
of what you can and can't say on on
Twitter
the on the one the one perspective that
I can understand and I think he has he's
gone near making this point on a couple
of occasions is that if a government
democratically if a democratic
government decides to through the
Democratic process pass a law
um in terms of what the social media
companies shouldn't shouldn't shouldn't
do the Democratic thing to do is to
respect that law I understand that
um which is different from the online
safety bill because that's
Outsourcing yeah that that decision to
the tech companies yeah and and then you
know if if a government does that well
then it's the work of civil society and
and frankly of our parliamentarians to
make sure that we don't pass censorious
laws
um but I think in the light of as you
say we there is and it's kind of like
this this
fudge of soft law making where the laws
are that the companies have to
there's a lot of latitude there's a lot
of room for them to decide how they take
on things like misinformation and
disinformation
so the proof we're then putting some
degree about what how they decide to
take that on and what they decide to do
how they decide to respond to it I think
it would be important
um that if they are getting requests to
take down lawful speech
that those are resisted I think that's a
really clear bright red line that you
can draw and I think the other thing is
that if the platforms feel that laws
have been passed that ask them to censor
things that would mean that then the
right to free speech wasn't being
protected that a company might look to
challenge that legally in the same way
that actually brother watch we are so we
we are gearing up uh for a legal
challenge against the UK's counter
disinformation unit because it's our um
understanding from what we know that
they they
um have negatively impacted people's
right to to free speech in in this
country and we're Gathering more
um evidence about that we've got
crowdfunder and um we'll go the whole
way um legally if we have to wow
um we've talked a little bit about uh
facial recognition already you have just
done a report at Big Brother watch
what can you tell us about the state of
facial recognition in the UK um
facial recognition is a quite extreme
surveillance capability and one of our
main interests is live facial
recognition where you have a camera that
scans your face and tries tries to
determine who you are in real time it's
the kind of thing that is seen fairly
commonly in China and it has been used
in Russia at protests for example around
the rest of the world particularly the
Democratic world it's a very
controversial surveillance tactic but
unfortunately in the UK it has been used
by police more and more often and we're
seeing now uh post covered suddenly a
really rapid growth in the use of the
tactics so it was used in London this
weekend the police took out live facial
recognition cameras
um some it's also in the private sector
used how so they at the moment they will
take out a police van with a camera on
top facial recognition camera and scan
people as they walk past so typically
you might scan tens of thousands of
people in fact this was used at the
um coronation so tens of thousands of
people obviously were they're
not looking for criminals or anything
like that they then have a watch list of
people that they're looking for and they
always say we're only looking for
serious
um criminals but what we actually find
is that they they can include people who
aren't suspected of any offense
um in some cases they put people on
there who have
possibly have mental health problems
people that they think might pose a harm
to themselves or to others there have
been protesters put on these um lists so
you can load tens of thousands of faces
onto a facial recognition watch list and
then take the camera out and see who
walks past
um and
um it effectively
means that you're a walking ID card
um and it I think what's most troubling
about this is obviously a serious
expansion of the surveillance state to
have a live facial recognition cameras
in in the Democratic world
and you know you don't need to read an
awful lot of dystopian fiction or watch
many dystopian films to understand where
that can go and to have you know real
time basically AI prison guards on the
streets you know watching people being
able to identify people from street
corners without their consent without
asking them who they are asking to show
an idea or whatever but it reverses the
the presumption of innocence and I think
that's been a theme that we've seen
really over the past 20 years is that
increasingly the the
um suspicion from the state towards the
public
um is really quite extreme and we are
treated like a nation of of suspects
um where you now have to prove your
innocence in a way
um you know the reason that ID cards
were so controversial is because you
know the notion of the Freeborn
Englishman I don't have to I haven't
show my identity to anyone prove myself
to anyone or answer any question unless
you've suspected me of doing something
wrong I'm just go you go about your
business freely with these technologies
that principle is being turned on its
head where the state says now I have a
right to know who you are where you are
in terms of online safety Bill what's on
your phone what photos you have who you
send them to
um at all times to just so we know that
you're not a bad person it's that you're
not a criminal yeah that's that that's a
truly disturbing
um kind of approach to Security today
anyone's not already convinced by that
being disturbing and weren't convinced
by what happened through covid then I
suggest as I said earlier look at what's
happening in China where they're ahead
of this and London I if they're not
mistaken has is outside of China is the
city with the most amount of CCTV stores
in the world so we're pretty close to
that dystopia China is the blueprint for
for a high-tech surveillance State
that's where all the the you know a lot
of tech is trained and modeled and
that's how it works and you would be
surprised or not maybe by the amount of
people in the police that I have spoken
to who when I have used the China
comparison as a obviously as negative
because it's a genocidal authoritarian
dictatorship they've said well the crime
rates are very low with with no hint of
irony genuinely I mean genuinely the
reason in some degree we import so much
Chinese Tech into this country is
because there are lots of people
unfortunately that that actually don't
see that as a big problem can we talk
about the Chinese Tech
um so uh you mentioned before we started
talking uh off camera there's there's
two there's face watch which is English
Tech firm but then there's hike vision
camera which is a Chinese is and so
what's the difference between these are
the two main
um uh companies that that for face
facial recognition in the UK well hi I'm
hike Vision has been used with facial
recognition with um
face watch in
Southern Co-op supermarkets of all
places
um but actually hike vision is without
facial recognition although they do have
lots of advanced capabilities often hike
vision is is everywhere if you look in
your office your kids school GP surgery
uh
you'll see these cameras everywhere hike
Vision cameras
um they're the biggest surveillance
camera company in the world owned by the
Chinese government
um we have
um hundreds of thousands if not more
hike vision cameras all over the UK the
majority of the cameras owned by public
authorities in this country are hike
Vision
um and from our point of view this is a
really big problem first of all from a
security point of view these are known
to have vulnerabilities they're made by
um the the Chinese State effectively
um and you know we're even seeing
recently stories coming out about the
extent of Chinese spying in the UK and
the risks that that compose I mean the
many of these cameras are in government
Department buildings but as far as we
know it's just the hardware so we don't
know that the Chinese it's not not
necessarily Huawei 2.0 because the CCP
don't necessarily have access to the
footage from the cameras well
um I think this is a question that the
the security and intelligence agencies
hopefully are looking into and answering
but it's certainly a risk I think it's
it's more than Huawei 2.0 it's Huawei on
steroids because these cameras are
everywhere they can often have
microphones
um Advanced analytic capabilities
um and there have there have been
documented cases there was an Italian
investigation where they found that one
of these cameras was sending vast
amounts of unauthorized signals to
servers in China
if that were happening the security
consequences are so severe you can
barely begin to get your mind around it
um so it's something that absolute needs
to be looked at other than the fact that
that means that millions and millions of
pounds of taxpayers money
are going to a genocidal regime that's
involved in you know these Camp these
hike Vision cameras are on the corners
of the concentration camps where uyghurs
are being we are being interned I mean
yeah purely from an ethical point of
view from Human Rights point of view
um this Tech should should not be
anywhere in this country from a security
point of view it's it's it's very very
concerning it's uh the um there's a
about two months ago I think they found
the CCP spy outside of MI6 pointed which
is it's it's beyond all while because
it's so it's actually it's quite funny
how ludicrous it seems more like a gray
and green novel that that you know they
can collect this sort of data on us and
um absolutely terrifying at the same
time
um so uh
with uh facial recognition do uh the
home office said that they've been
lobbying for more use of this legally
where are we at with with facial
recognition is there is there a sort of
what can be what can be said about it to
to restrict it um
requests that Christopher the policing
Minister
um has been having meetings with a
facial recognition company called face
watch whilst they were under
investigation by the data Watchdog the
Ico
um and the Ico did find that this
company had breached a whole string of
privacy laws basically privacy
obligations under data Protection Law
um in terms of how this technology is
being used in fact in retail settings
you know on Shoppers on us when we go
into Super into supermarkets actually
the co-op supermarket in particular in
this case from a complaint that we made
so the policing minister is meeting this
company whilst they're under
investigation and then saying to the Ico
the regulator
um
unless we get a favorable outcome I'm
going to write to you publicly and say
how important I think this technology is
basically threatening them and to us
that reads sort of uncomfortably close
to an interference with what's supposed
to be an independent investigation
um what we've seen in the rest of Europe
is that where companies start trying to
use facial recognition surveillance
um Regulators have stepped in and
stopped it because they don't want
because you know the law stops IT and
actually we have the same law as as
um Europe on on data protection at the
moment that's about to change
um and I think you know we don't want to
become a surveillance State and I think
everyone recognizes at the moment there
are problems with shoplifting there are
problems with law enforcement full stop
you can have your shop robbed you can
have clear pictures of who who it is
they can come in every day and do the
same thing and you'd be very lucky if
the police do anything about it I think
we've read enough stories about that but
for the answer to be to build this giant
surveillance State I mean it's
it's scary because it it changes the
nature of the country that we live in
but it's also ludicrous because it's
we're not struggling for evidence on
these serious criminals
um it's more to do with police
resourcing and whatever chronic
mismanagement has gone on in policing
for a very very long time but
unfortunately I think that some of these
Advanced surveillance Technologies are
now being touted as the Silver Bullet
answer and if we go down that road
we're going to end up in a very strange
place because policing is in a really
bad position
um and there's a lot of extreme
surveillance technology out there that
people will try to sell in to plug the
gaps you made a comment earlier in the
conversation that the police you seem to
support the surveillance Thing by
referencing China and how little crime
there is there
is that to suggest that the police more
generally do you think the police
support this direction rather than
having support in in uh you know I don't
know more funding uh more support from
the government is is the is this where
the police want to go well I'm talking
about senior people in the police
sometimes when I speak to officers who
are working on facial recognition
um there are different views I mean bear
in mind these people are if you're a
police officer who's on a facial
recognition deployment you're stood on
the street looking at an iPad waiting
for a match to flag it's not traditional
policing
um and it and the technology is wrong a
lot I think statistics at the moment is
around 90 of the flags have been
misidentifications actually wrongly
flagging people
um 90 yeah it's been completely useless
it's been it has been completely useless
um it will get better there's no doubt
about that how much is it costing us
they've never put a number on it but
it's way into the Millions wow that's
our money of course yes uh Millions
spent on something with a 90 failure
rate great uh on a more light note it
seems we've pretty heavily covered
dystopian Britain 2023 just there
um BBC verify I wanted to get your
opinion on this uh last week Mariana
spring was revealed to have lied on her
CV which I see is
um a little bit of a tad ironic but
what's the big brother
um Big Brother watch uh take on BBC
verify is it something that is a good to
tackle misinformation is this
information or is it a little bit faster
I just think it's something we expect
all journalists to do and that all
journalists have always done I think the
what's problematic is the idea that it's
it's a special category of new
journalism that has unique Authority as
well
um and and I think then in particular to
you know have one individual who's kind
of the face of it
um who who might not be as qualified as
other colleagues in in the organization
you know that that obviously has come
with with real risks I think the
personal attacks are obviously horrible
um and then justify a lot of of uh
this kind of ongoing battle between this
whole conversation around
should we have things like BBC verifying
around particular correspondence and so
on
um but I also think we can't hold back
on on criticizing it I mean this is
basically a whole new category of
Journalism that's been invented
overnight
um that that you know license fee payers
are having to having to fit the bill for
um that's often seems to be of a fairly
poor quality and I think that there are
I'm sure you are hearing and you know
many journalists and people in
Westminster are hearing that there are
some journalists in the BBC and other
organizations that have sprung up with
these roles that have a bit more of a
critical view about just how new and
unique and special this this
disinformation correspondent type uh
reporting really is everyone loves good
journalism you know I don't but I think
there's something about the claim to
Unique credentials and Authority
um
and also where the where the the
attention is focused is highly political
that's obvious huge amount of of
incorrect information was given
during covid about for example the
impact of
um the protect you know you will not get
covered if you have vaccine uh you will
not be able to pass on Covert of a
vaccine vaccine passports are the key to
Freedom we simply can't survive without
them never really saw those facts
checked in the same way that you saw say
you know a really marginal out their
view that was shared by a few people on
a corner of the internet that was then
used to mischaracterize and malign
critics of government policy if you know
what I mean seems like a surface level
manifestation of two drastically
Different World Views that we're in
enjoying or suffering in Britain which
is one where there's this disinformation
a world of disinformation that is a
great evil that must be tackled and
another of people who believe in free
speech and
um and it's uh it seems like there's
this tension between it because I I just
to speak to Progressive friends who
support this uh and and then I speak to
say liberal friends who against it and
there's that tension it is quite a
popular I think it seems to be quite
popular amongst some groups the the BBC
verify yes uh but isn't as always isn't
the truth somewhere in between I mean
like disinformation is a real problem
um
between
States you know a state level of
disinformation is a real thing and you
would hope that journalists
um would help to identify where it crops
up and what the impact is
um but I think it's become a bit more to
do with
um policing individuals and what people
say to each other and that's just like
the hustle and bustle of conversations
um like imagine a disinformation
agent in a pub you know going around
policing and correcting everyone and
what they're saying and determining and
what that's kind of what it's like on on
on Twitter by the way that's happening
that's what city Khan's mate whatever uh
campaign was uh so that's you know yeah
don't give them any ideas but it's kind
of the it's kind of the the equivalent
thing is that you know basically we're
plea it's gone to the point where we're
policing speech I think the most obvious
to Me comparison with um counter
disinformation is counter extremism that
we saw in the naughties so it comes from
something that's a real problem
um it involves then a degree of social
surveillance and peer-to-peer
surveillance and peer-to-peer policing
and it's can so obviously be it
orientates around a loose woolly
definition that no one quite knows what
it is
um and uh it can so obviously be
exploited for political power and to and
to and to increase
um political power I think the
difference is that in the naughties when
there was
a whole string of of powers
um grown and and laws passed around
counter-extremism the the left in
particular was was a bit more prepared
to take a critical view
um
and be a bit kind of Switched on about
the way that that could be politically
exploited this time if it seems as
though a lot of Civil Society has been
co-opted and bought in and particularly
in the digital rights space
um I have to say I find it
um really really disappointing that so
many of the groups that we will narrowly
work really constructively with and
really well with
um have somewhat been kind of co-opted
into that as well and they can't quite
articulate
um how that isn't a free speech
violation yeah and in a way that just
didn't happen with counter-extremism
that's the fault line right there it's
the it's the it's where is the free
speech and then where is this such a
great evil that we need to tackle it and
how much and that debate continues as
you say from uh from the from the 90s
um silky Carlo what a fascinating
conversation where can people uh follow
you and find your work uh where big
brotherwatch.org.uk
um big brother at Big Brother watch on
Twitter I'm at silky Carlo and uh yeah
we've got a huge amount coming up uh in
the rest of the year what's next as well
so we're gearing up for um further legal
action in relation to the county
disinformation unit yep that's going to
definitely be one to watch and deepening
our investigation on that and upping our
campaign against facial recognition so
you know I do think this is a it's quite
a unique moment in time that we're
living through with the this
extraordinary growth of Technology
um and how invasive a lot of the
surveillance and censorship technology
is for anyone who is you know concerned
about this at all please please follow
us support us
um because I do think we've got the
power to make a difference now we've won
some of our big campaigns you know we
won the campaign against the invention
of legal but harmful speech
um we know and we won the campaign
against mandatory vaccine passports
um that's one of our biggest campaigns
that we've ever ran to League challenges
that went into that as well I think we
know that when we have public support
behind us we can fight these David and
Goliath fights and we can win and Now's
the Time to do it brilliant stuff silky
Carlo thank you so much thank you
foreign
[Music]